one of my questions to you is when when
were you most nervous
interviewing whom who would it be it was
it was sidney poitier
and uh diana ross and for diana ross
because
it was such a phenomenal moment for me
that i remember when you remember in
diana ross are you old enough to
remember diana ross in central park
i was there no you worked
was there with andy warhol
there when it started raining and she
had to the concert had
air i was on stage there
it was the most incredible thing of my
life one of them
wow it was an opry of no idea it was
unfucking believable i have a
seared into my memory is the angle where
i was standing directly behind her
with the chiffon my eyes are watering
now that you were there
oh my god you were there the chiffon
blowing
the it had just gotten dark the
spotlights coming from the towers
hitting her the rain coming down in
sheets the tower's now
starting to shake which is why they
stopped the concert because they were
worried it was going to collapse on the
audience
and her singing ain't no mountain high
enough
yes oh my god you were there
i'll never forget it my head's swelling
thinking about it anyway
so after that concert well i wasn't
there i was watching from my
little apartment in baltimore i was so
in awe of that whole moment
the next day i called
trying to find diana ross of course i
did not so i ended up with her
production company
so she had if anybody goes to youtube
and sees it
there were these diamond earrings and i
was thinking wow
one day i want to have diamond earrings
like that and i remember asking
two things what mascara was she wearing
that did not run
and they told me lancome waterproof so
to this day i still use
lancome waterproof and what size
diamonds were those and they told me 10
carat diamonds
so my whole career i was like
in baltimore making you know 22 000
a year but i'm saving up so i can get
those ten carat diamonds now when i
finally interviewed her she said
they were not ten they were five carats
each and i went
wow i went and got the tens and i didn't
have to have the tens
but anyway i always spent but that
moment
seared into my my my memory the
power and confidence and authority
and just the the majesty of that
of that moment i'm so glad we're having
this conversation because sometimes i
look back on that and i go was it just
me
no was it did i over estimate
what that moment was that was i mean
no who has moments like that in concerts
anymore i mean
and it's i think it probably was was
more
emphasized because more pronounced in
our memory
because it did have to end you know if
the concert had just continued
maybe it would not have been the same
memory but because they had to end the
concert and i was so worried oh my god
she's holding the microphone i hope she
doesn't get struck by lightning oh my
god
and so that whole thing you know i
thought she was going to get
electrocuted
i didn't it was a real thought but she
wouldn't get she wouldn't she wouldn't
get out of the rain she stayed there for
the audience
even that to me was such a pronounced
thing
like wow she is risking her own
you know safety to be here for the
audience oh
incredible literally incredible
and then oprah i got to after so we all
scattered through central park and andy
warhol and i and my date
went uh back and had dinner and then
went and watched the playback of the
concert with diana
it was well it was so you could do
anything
i mean i i i had a little you know i had
my forrest gump period
i was kind of in in play before i went
into my gentleman retirement montecito